good morning of my name is our spirits
us I'm in here for two minutes going
like this very creepy essentially this
is a activity that I used my celery
great class when I'm teaching fractions
and really it's about consolidating
students knowledge and understanding of
the equivalent fractions what is it it
is a game it is paid these played in
pairs and as I said it is used to
consolidate students understanding of
equivalent fractions I like using after
I'm actually taught the concept as a way
off as I said consolidating that
knowledge it's fun it's engaging and it
really differentiates itself and I'll
explain that a bit more once I get into
what you need it and what it is what you
need is a fractional sheet which is just
look something like this it is
essentially what you want to know is one
of these rows represents one hole so
that one roll is one hole that's
obviously a half so on and so forth and
the sheet is then the students they're
turning out and how it works or
something like that you can go for a
more structured sort of sheet depending
on your class which would look that one
gives a bit of an indication of those
fractures to help them along so
depending on your students and what
level they're at and now sent they have
you can do that so you need that sheet
you need a numerator die which is
basically your normal die but I've
labeled it out 1 1 2 2 3 4 quite easy
there just use one of those dot stickers
and you put them on likewise you need a
denominator die and it's labeled the
fraction denominator 2 3 4 6 8 and 12
and you can go different textures and
pens how do you play essentially the
place take turns at rolling both the
peers of dice and they get a fracture
they roll a numerator and a denominator
and they get a fraction from that they
must cover that fraction on their
fraction wall sheets now there are
options if your role for example a four
and rate you can just simply rock
straight in fights you can shave half
you can shave six 12's we all know that
some
for every single one but essentially um
it's time I'm sorry first person to roll
to cover their whole wall shade it in
actually is the winner and the reason
why does differentiate itself is
basically you got your lower ability
kids who would probably be quite literal
in terms of whatever they roll they
color in whereas your higher academic
kids would get a bit more creative and
start you know changing their equivalent
fractions and things like that thank